a constant pressure calorimeter can be
used to find the change in enthalpy for
a chemical reaction let's look at the
chemical reaction between an aqueous
solution of silver nitrate and aqueous
solution of sodium chloride to form a
precipitate of silver chloride and an
aqueous solution of sodium nitrate
let's say we have 25.0 milliliters of a
0.100 molar solution of silver nitrate
and 25.0 milliliters of a 0.100 molar
solution of sodium chloride both
solutions are initially at a temperature
of
25.000 degrees celsius
next we add our two solutions to our
calorimeter which is made of two coffee
cups and since the top coffee cup is
loose fitting this reaction is under the
constant pressure of the atmosphere so
this is constant pressure calorimetry
after the two aqueous solutions mix the
reaction occurs and we watch the
thermometer in the calorimeter in this
case the temperature of the solution
increases and the final temperature the
highest one reached in our experiment is
25.781 degrees
celsius so the change in the temperature
of the solution would be the final
temperature minus the initial
temperature which is 25.781
minus 25.0
which is equal to
positive 0.781
degrees celsius
the total volume of solution would be 25
plus 25 which is equal to 50.0
milliliters of solution if we assume the
density of the solution is one gram per
milliliter fifty point zero milliliters
is equal to fifty point zero grams
next we need to solve for the heat
gained by the water and we can use the q
is equal to mc delta t equation so we're
solving for the heat which is symbolized
by q
m is the mass of our solution which we
saw was 50.0 grams so we can plug that
in
we can assume that the specific heat of
the solution is the same as the specific
heat of water which is 4.18 joules per
gram degree celsius and the change in
the temperature of the solution was
0.781 degrees celsius so we can plug
that in as well
grams cancels out degrees celsius
cancels out
and we find that q
is equal to
positive 1.63
times 10 to the second joules
the positive sign means that energy was
gained by the water but let's think
about the distinction between system
and surroundings
the system consists of the reactants and
products for our particular reaction and
the surroundings are everything else
which includes the water
so in this case since the temperature of
the surroundings increased right we saw
an increase in the temperature that
means that heat flowed from the system
to the surroundings and so the
surroundings increased in energy and
that's what we see with this positive
sign here
if we assume a perfect transfer of heat
from the system to the surroundings if
the surroundings gained energy that
means the system lost energy so if we're
thinking about the heat transferred for
the reaction
it's the same in magnitude 1.63 times 10
to the second joules however we need to
put a negative sign in here which
indicates that energy was given off by
the reaction
the heat that's transferred under
constant pressure is equal to the change
in the enthalpy of the reaction delta h
however let's find the change in
enthalpy delta h in terms of kilojoules
per mole of silver chloride for our
units
since silver chloride is one of our
products we first need to find moles of
our reactants and we're going to do that
using the molarity equation which says
that molarity is equal to moles divided
by liters
for our silver nitrate solution the
concentration was
0.100 molar and trying to solve for
moles so that's x the volume of our
silver nitrate solution was 25.0
milliliters which is point zero two five
zero liters
so we solve for x and we get point zero
zero
two five zero
so that's how many moles of silver
nitrate that we started with and it's
the exact same calculation for sodium
chloride as well so this is also how
many moles of sodium chloride we have
next we go back to our balanced chemical
equation and we can see we have
coefficients of one in front of silver
nitrate in front of sodium chloride and
in front of silver chloride therefore
we're also going to produce
.00250 moles of silver chloride
next we're going to calculate the change
in the enthalpy delta h for our reaction
the heat that was transferred was
negative 1.63
times 10 to the second joules
and we're going to divide that by the
moles of silver chloride which was
.00250
moles of silver chlorides
this is equal to negative 65
200
joules per mole of silver chloride and
we could convert that into kilojoules
and so this is equal to negative 65.2
kilojoules per
mole of silver chloride
we could stop right here and give this
as our final answer but let's keep going
and convert to kilojoules per mole of
reaction
first let's rewrite this we have
negative 65.2
kilojoules per mole
of silver chloride
and what it means by kilojoules per mole
of reaction is how the reaction is
written in the balanced equation down
here
so if we look at the balanced equation
there's one mole
of silver chloride for how the reaction
is written so we can write a conversion
factor of one mole
of silver chloride per one
mole of reaction and writing it this way
for the conversion factor
the moles of silver chloride would
cancel out and give us negative 65.2
kilojoules per
mole of reaction so this could also be
our final answer
finally the negative sign means that we
have an exothermic reaction the reaction
gave off energy and this value when you
do when you do a constant pressure
calorimetry experiment is often a little
bit lower than the actual value because
in reality there's not always a perfect
transfer of heat from the reaction to
the water often some of the energy is
lost to the environment